I guess this is a perfect way since
there was a glitch in the first overall
selection let's bring in the man who's
been a quarterback consultant of Joe
burrows and Jordan Palmer Jordan it
looks like two is gonna be the number
one overall pick I guess that might but
that might have been the glitch what do
you think funny you telling that story
and it sounds eerily similar to my first
fantasy football driving years ago you
know internet was kind of a new thing
Bonni sponsoring remotely and players
like TJ who spins Auto we're getting
drafted high and uh yeah so the owner
all these all these coaches never got a
chance to play fantasy now to see what
the common folk deal with I mean we were
in all seriousness I mean it does remind
me of a fantasy draft but and obviously
the NFL does not want it to resemble a
fantasy draft and it doesn't want it to
have a moment like we're talking about
in our fantasy drafts but just like in
our fantasy drafts you can stop a clock
I mean a can it to fix some sort of
technical glitch should it happen
I mean you know life could go on if this
does happen on Thursday night Jordan you
know what I'm saying yeah it's crazy and
you won't have like greasy fingers from
wings to blame too many IPAs typical
fantasy football you know
draft guys can blame but uh yeah I think
it's gonna be fascinating for me I'm
kind of outside looking in on this I
just saw how the drafts gonna go down
and the how the effects that this will
have on the draft in terms of their
inability to get physicals some guys are
gonna go higher than they would have yes
so you know things would somebody's
gonna go lower because they didn't get a
chance to win over that team in a
meeting
so just to watch how it's gonna go down
and then the residual effects afterwards
is just to be fascinating
Jordan Palmer here on the Rich Eisen
show okay so how did you get hooked up
with Burrell
I mean how does how does this go down as
you know him for a long time or did you
did you start chatting with him during
last year at LSU what's your connection
to Jo well I'd heard about him I'm
pretty connected through the Elite 11
with a lot of the high school kids
coming out and and a lot of the guys who
were playing on Sundays or guys that I
saw when they were younger but
being said to see a lot of guys so Joe
didn't necessarily stick out from that
standpoint but as he left and went to
LSU I just kind of followed that I ran
into coach border on who was my older
brother Carson he was the right line
coach at USC I'm on my way back oh yeah
right so I think the last time I saw
coach oh I had zits and braces and he
sounded and looked exactly the same
[Laughter]
damned Arnold and Josh Allen and and he
said hey I said well I admit a joke I
said when you're gonna have a
quarterback in this green room he said
two years and so he kind of I think Joe
was just in the transfer portal coming
over whatever it was and and so he's on
my radar I watched 2018 LSU so not the
fasces in the disease before and if you
really actually watch it and I watched
it in real time people are now going
back and watch the tape if you watch it
in real time and you listen to the
announcers and you kind of knew it was
happening at LSU
Jill was putting the ball on the money
the first half of the season his stats
were bad the second half they were good
and so they ended up being like at the
end but they led NC double-a and dropped
passes in 2018 and so there was more
there than met the eye and I know LSU
fans were watching the games but scout I
don't think a lot of the other people
and so when I saw that I go man I want
to see this guy in person so I invited
him out to one of my QB summit camps
which their camps that I run and young
guys and high school guys come but I
always have a couple of college
counselors and it was funny because I
had a couple of lesser-known college
quarterbacks and and and they were no
one knew who the Baroque it was and so
that was just in July but when I had him
out there he was throwing with Sam
darling Josh Johnson these older guys
were out there hmm
and they all were all kind of said the
same thing we said man this guy's a
little different a little more confident
everybody else a little more mature and
when you hear him talk about his team
and it sounds like they got a chance to
go on a run and when I learned more
about it I actually went on a couple
different media pieces in July and said
look there's a kid no one's talking
about this guy's chance to go to go
really high in the draft when the
Heisman was national championship so I
at least saw the writing on the wall
that that was potential I didn't know
he's gonna do what he did but there was
enough
key ingredients there I think you could
see it so what does he need to work on
seems like he makes all the throws
Jordan but what it what did you see and
tweak and what do you think he brings in
terms of the skill set about working on
as a professional well you know I get a
chance to spend three straight months
with these guys which is the biggest
time period from when they start playing
football to the end of a 15 year career
the draft phase is actually represents
the greatest opportunity in my opinion
to take a step because they don't have
school class marketing things the
friends aren't trying to get em to go
out they don't have teammates they can
just focus on themselves so when I do at
that time is I break down into two areas
of when I focus on one is what needs to
be developed which is a nice way of
saying what needs to be fixed yes and
the second one is what just needs to be
introduced like what have you just not
done yet because they didn't ask you to
do that you're so part of that as
coverages that they're gonna see well
they don't run all the same coverages in
the NFL they do in college and with Joe
they were from week four on they were
basically in a five-man protection every
every pass play meaning they only had
the five guys blocking they had five
guys out in a row and Joe had a lot of
protection responsibilities to be able
to you know to allocate for the the
rushes that were coming and so the big
part was just getting him caught up on
six member sections and seven man
protections and clay actions all the
under center footwork he was
predominantly in gun so a lot of a lot
of that stuff I did with Joe is really
just introducing him to what he's gonna
see we didn't really spend a lot of time
getting him ready for the draft I spent
the majority of time trying to get him
ready to play his rookie year okay and
then the issue of him being chosen first
overall at the I spoke to your brother
about this last week at the Super Bowl
that was a big conversation man about
does he really want to be picked by the
Bengals and then we started you know we
start tracing you know your brother
thinks that they didn't really want to
win TJ Houshmandzadeh whose name he
mentioned I know that Joe's been
throwing to him or at least he was part
of his training how much does that play
into what's going down Thursday night
does Joe really is he all in if he gets
chosen by the Bengals to
yeah I think so yeah I think so I mean
he's he's a guy who from a confidence
standpoint feels like if he's on the
team that that they got a chance because
they have him and that that totally may
sound cocky right to one a couple of
listeners but that is the difference
here between do to play in the league
and the ones who hold trophies is that
they genuinely believe because they have
them they're good enough to win and so
and Jose you know I think he's looking
at this and going man I think if I can
step into a program he took over a high
school program turned that around
he went to LSU and they did things I'd
never done before and so I feel like
he's stepping in the league and feels
like he can win with anybody and I think
if you look at the bangles if you look
at any of these teams or a rumor to you
know to try and get to one really any of
the teams on the top there's reasons to
believe that if they have Joe they can
win and there's also things to be
concerned about and so I think that's
across the board and then connecting the
dots between my brother and I look that
was a Marvin Lewis ran team that was
different
times have changed some for the better
some for the worst I don't even know but
when you change the regime things change
and so I don't even know that I my
opinion even matters because it's from
nine years ago you know and so I think
Joe's looking at this going alright
leave you know if they're if he's
blessed and they take him number one
he's looking around at a roster he
thinks he can win list and a division he
thinks have been competitive in and I
think he'd look at any situation that
way
Jordan Palmer quarterback consultant
former quarterback in the league right
here on the Rich Eisen show so you work
with Jordan love as well there's been so
much comparison between love and mahomes
boy that that that sounds unfair but I'm
wondering what you've seen from love and
his skillset that might be mahomes like
Jordan yeah I got to spend some time
with with Jordan love this during the
structuring as well a lot less time that
I spent with Perot but enough to fall in
love with his traits for sure I had
spent a long time with Patrick during
the space too and and in his last year
at Texas Tech and I think the
similarities is certainly not there it's
not like every comparisons of Joe
Barroso
Joe Montana and these people that just
like how are you come up with that
comparison Brady's the one that Brady is
the one that that that even Kevin Faulk
is mentioned and obviously he he won
Super Bowls with with Brady so you're
hearing Brady with bottle in the homes
would love your flat out so I just
compared people to like all compare
Jordan love right now when Patrick was
at this phase but I'm not in comparing
you know a rookie with a 21-year vet and
Tom Brady right right so but if I were
to compare Patrick at this point and
Jordan at this point yeah there is a lot
of similarities the similarities the
ability to throw from different arm
angles which to a casual plan probably
doesn't mean a ton but it would think
about it like this if you can throw from
different arm angles consider and the
result is consistent then what that
means is you're gonna get more quality
attempts like you got a better chance to
complete more balls then if you have
elite arm talent which they both do and
then you add on their they can both move
around and I think the future of the
position is the quarterbacks ability to
create time and space sometimes that's a
yard sometimes that's getting out of
pocket so both of those guys Patrick and
Jordan love have the ability to throw
from different arm angles consistently
with elite arm talent and move okay so
there's the part where I would connect
those two the part that's different and
this is a giant difference is the system
that Patrick played it in high school
the system that he played in attack and
the way I met Patrick mahomes clickings
breezy sent him like said hey I got this
thing he's a sophomore you got to get
your hands on him kind of thing so I
hadn't I had never met the kid till I
showed up and so but what they ran at
Texas Tech they didn't play a lot of
defense I mean there was they had to
score 40 50 60 points he had to throw
four five six touchdowns so he's had
this Patrick had so many shootouts his
whole life he was just so much foot on
the gas and then when you don't play
defense you can't turn it over because
if you lose a possession that's like
giving them seven points so he also had
this balance at Texas Tech where he was
aggressive but made good decisions
didn't throw a lot of tax the difference
what you're in love is he didn't plan
that prolific offense in high school he
didn't claim that prolific offense in
college can he do all those things I
think he can do all the same things but
one of the unique traits that Patrick
has that not many fans give give credit
to is the fact that he has been in so
many shootouts that's why when they're
down whatever they were down they can
come back and win because that's his
mentality and that's the difference that
I see between those two all right and a
few minutes left to have with you Jordan
Palmer I want to turn you I guess and a
member of the paparazzi and an evaluator
a few years in darn 'old Mayfield true
Biscay in terms of the consistency level
or in terms of what we what we believe
maybe is their future which one is the
closest to having already an opinion
that we could form as to whether they're
gonna work out in this league so far
well you got for me on there yeah I
think I would say on the on the
unfortunate side of it I would say it's
true Biscay because when you give when
you give a guy a really good opportunity
which is a good defense some good
weapons you know a quality play collar
and head coach which i think is what
he's been given which you can't then say
is well I just wasn't ready for that
opportunity yet you know I needed to be
in year two or needed a little bit more
experience because this is a right place
right time league and it's also a wrong
place wrong time league different great
players who just were at the wrong spot
at the wrong time and there's been
pretty good decent guys who are at the
right place in the right time and you
know some of them have gold jackets and
so with Mitch I would say I'm there
I think Nick Foles is going to come in
and kind of be that little myth piece I
don't know that he's a long term
solution but he's gonna be a great
missing piece for them and then between
Baker and Sam I would say that Baker has
been given more quality opportunities
just with the personnel around him I
think Sam the huge discrepancy between
the Browns and the Jets in terms of
office personnel both of them have had
multiple coordinators both of them have
had ups and downs for different reasons
Sam cuz he got sick and Baker was just
some off-the-field stuff and so in
distraction so I think you know there's
still we still got to see more out of
those guys
Sam hasn't played a full 16 games yet
you know in the two years that he's
played and so that will
as much as I love both those guys that's
why I'd say he's right there but I do
think if you give Sam the weapon I think
that's gonna end up when it's all said
and done looking a lot better and your
guy Josh Allen it's his division to win
now don't you think right yeah that's
wide open it's wide open it's
interesting because I work with your did
him to taking over in New England a
little bunch of guys who hang out out
here all right did you just open the
door I want to walk in and how ready you
think Stidham is because it seems like
Belichick might be ready to just hand
the job to Stidham we'll see what
happens on Thursday and Friday nights
but what do you think of stidham's
readiness I think he's absolutely ready
he's been thrown in a lot of weird spots
and handled himself well he had a pretty
he had a challenging childhood and had
to become the man of the house at a
young age and so starting just with zap
right there and then to go through
Baylor with all the Art Briles if you
guys were at all that controversy and
you know stuff stepping down transfer
and going to Auburn getting thrown to a
tough spot and you know really really
playing well and and then last offseason
Jarrett was in as good as spot as you
can be in for a young guy to learn so
last offseason he's in the room with Tom
Brady and Brian Hoyer between Tom Brady
and Brian Hoyer they had 31 years of NFL
experience 27 in that system so he just
got a year at MIT for football and I
know what he can do physically and from
a confidence standpoint so I think he's
in a great spot I also would say it'll
be interesting to see what the pictures
to Thursday and Friday because if they
want to put competition in that room you
do it with another young guy and so that
could be interesting but I think jared
is if you give him the ball and put him
in there I don't know that he's gonna I
don't know that he's gonna come out
Jordan appreciate the time and the
insight man you've got tons of it we'll
give you a call later in the week for
for next and see how it all comes out
I'd love to get your two cents on on all
of it always appreciate the call and the
time you're the best thanks rich right
back catches if it's Jordan Palmer
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here